ces deux soldats séparatistes
brandissent le drapeau de l'ancien yémen
du sud
depuis plusieurs semaines les forces du
conseil de transition du sud continue de
résister à l'offensive des troupes pro
gouvernementales qui cherche à prendre
le contrôle de zindjibar situe à l'est
d'aden
la deuxième ville du pays ce week-end
encore plus d'une dizaine de combattants
auraient été tuées dans les deux camps
les séparatistes assure être prêt à
poursuivre encore longtemps cette guerre
contre les forces gouvernementales
mon message pour eux est le suivant il
serait mieux pour eux qu'ils se rendent
ou bat en retraite
il ne devrait pas essayer d'entrer à
abyane parce qu'on est un mur humain
ils ne pourront entrer à abyane qu'en
marchant sur nos cadavres ce sera
impossible pour eux d'entrer à abyane
ces combats intenses surviennent après
la proclamation par les séparatistes de
l'autonomie du yémen du sud
une annonce faite le 26 avril dernier à
la suite de l'échec des négociations
pour un accord de paix avec le
gouvernement
accord qui prévoyait le partage du
pouvoir entre les deux parties ce
conflit entre les forces
gouvernementales et les séparatistes du
sud s'ajoute à une autre guerre bien
plus dévastatrices depuis 2014 les
rebelles houthi soutenu par l'iran
contre le nord du pays et la capitale
sanaa déserté par le gouvernement
désormais ans d'exil
face à cette insurrection la coalition
dirigée par l'arabie saoudite appuyé les
forces gouvernementales sans parvenir à
prendre l'ascendant
le conflit au yémen dure depuis plus de
quatre ans il a déjà tué des dizaines de
milliers de personnes dont de nombreux
civils selon l'onu
le yémen subi la pire crise humanitaire
au monde
[Musique]